ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
ومنظمه الصحه تخشى حصيله اسوا
انتظام المساعدات الدوليه لتركيا وبايدن
يؤكدوا لاردوغان استعداده لدعم انقره
مسؤولا بالامم المتحده يؤكد ان مواجهه
اثار الزلزال في سوريا تواجه عقبات
وعراقيل شتى
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النشره المفصله
تاتيكم من العربيه نبداها من تركيا حيث
اشارت اخر حصيله رسميه لاعداد الضحايا
جراء الزلزال الى مقتل 2900 وواحد وعشرين
شخصا وايضا الى جرح حوالي سته عشر الفا
بحسب اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فيما
سجل تدمير اكثر من سته الاف ومئتين وسبعه
عشر مبنى اما في سوريا فقد ارتفعت الحصيله
الى اكثر من 1440 قتيلا فيما دمر الزلزال
مئات المنازل ليفاقم من معاناه السوريين
في وقت عبرت الامم المتحده عن خشيتها من
تسجيل مزيد من الضحايا في سوريا وتركيا
جراء الزلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بك يا زيدان معنا زيدان يوم عصيب
بالامس اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه طبعا
وتعازينا الحاره لكل ذوي
الذين سقطوا في هذا الزلزال سواء كان في
سوريا او في تركيا هل ما زالت عمليات
البحث والانقاذ
وازاله الركام مستمره وهل من المتوقع ان
تستمر
يعني بعده ساعات او ايام قادمه
نعم طبعا عمليه ازاله الانقاض او
الدمار في المواقع التي ضربها البلدان
مستمره لم تتوقف ابدا
خلال الليله الماضيه وساعات المساء
الاثنين وطبعا من المتوقع ان تستمر لعده
ايام لان حجم الدمار كبير وبالتالي
طالما ان هناك
كتل خرسانيه
قد سقطت بفعل الزلزال هذا يعني هذه الكتل
هناك
عالقون ربما تستطيع
السلطات والطرق الانقاذ انقاذ الوصول
اليهم وانقاذ حياتهم في حال كانوا على قيد
الحياه طبعا لذلك العمليات ستستمر لعده
ايام لكن مع استمرار هذه العمليات من
المفترض وصول المزيد
من اطقم الانقاذ لدعم عمليات انقاذ
الحكومه التركيه بحاجه لاضعاف الاشخاص
الذين يعملون الان في هذا الموضوع موضوع
ازاله الانقاذ يوم امس كان الحديث من قبل
رئيس هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افاد عن تطوع او
انضمام اكثر من خمسين الف شخص الى كوادر
المؤسسه للمساعده في عمليات الدعم لكن لا
يعلم ان كان كل هذا العدد هو سيشارك فيه
الانقاب ام سيشارك في موضوع مثلا الاهتمام
بما مراكز الايواء او اهتمام
في مراكز الايواء لذلك تركيا بحاجه الى
نستطيع القول فرق انقاذ متخصصه وهذا ما
يبدو انه يعني بدا يصل تباعا عن طريق
اذربيجان
الفريق الذي اتجان ومكون من 370 شخص وصلوا
مساء الاثنين وايضا
الفرق الاخرى التي ستباعا الى تركيا
اعتبارا او ربما وصل بعضها الليله الماضي
لنبدا حتى الان الحكومه التركيه
لم تعلن رسميا عن اسماء
الفرق او الدول او اسماء الفرق التي وصلت
بشكل رسمي الى تركيا وباشرت عملها من فضلك
تحديثات هذا اليوم
لكن بالعموم حتى تفصل هذه الفرق بشكل امن
وسريع الى المناطق المدمره تتطلب على
الحكومه التركيه فتح الطرق التي انهار
بعضها وهذا فعلا ما شاهدناه يوم امس تحاول
السلطات التركيه فتح اعاده فتح الطرق او
ترميم بعض الطرق التي دمرت بسبب الزلزال
حتى يتسنى لسرقه الانقاذ سواء الانقاذ
التي وصلت من خارج البلاد او حتى
الانقاذ المحليه الموجوده في الولايات
الاخرى والذي ترغب بالوصول الى المنا
المنكوبه كل هذا يعني كل هؤلاء يحتاجون
اما طرق بريه سريعه للوصول الى
المنطقه المنكوبه او جسر جوي وهذا ما
يوفره حتى الان الجيش التركي
[موسيقى]
الانقاذ والتراكم الطبيه نعم طيب زيدان
قبل اربعين دقيقه تقريبا هناك تقارير
تتحدث زلزال اخر يضرب وسط تركيا هذه المره
بقوه خمسه على مقياس ريختر هل لديك اي
معلومات عن هذا الموضوع
نعم هذه هزات ما زالت تضرب
تحديد المناطق الجنوبيه
تركيا
[موسيقى]
هي نتيجه الانزالين
الذين ضربات كهرمان مرعش يوم امس الاول
بالقوه 7.7 والثاني من قوه 7.6 لذلك
الهزات الارتزاديه لم تتوقف وهي تثير
الرعب حقيقه في نفوس سكان هذه المنطقه
وايضا تزيد تزيد قلق السلطات التركيه مع
ان الهزات الاعتزازيه تؤدي الى مليار مزيد
من المباني التي تصدعت نوعا ما بسبب
الزلزال مع استمرار الهزات الاعتزابيه هذا
يعني ان المزيد من المباني
ستسقط وهذا ما دفع السلطان التركيه الصباح
امس بعد مباشره الى تعبير السكان من عدم
العوده الى منازلهم التي تصدعت او تشققت
والبقاء اما في مراكز او في اماكن مفتوحه
هذا طبعا ايضا ان هذه الهزات الاعتداديه
تعرق العمل
طرق الطوارئ والكوارث لذلك يعني اليوم
عمليه الوصول الى الناجين او رفع الانقاض
هي عمليه معقده نوعا انا امام هذه عمليه
تحديات عديده منها
الهزات الاعتزابيه ايضا منها تعطل الطرق
في بعض المناطق منها ايضا الظروف المناخيه
السيئه والثلوج التي تسقط بغزاره في بعض
المناطق في مناطقها في غازي عنتاب
وايضا في كهرمان مرعش كل هذه الظروف
الجويه السيئه ايضا اضافه الى العوامل
السابقه
وعرقل في بعض الاحيان العمل واحيانا اخرى
تعيق وصول الفرق الانقاذ او تواقل الانقاذ
الا الاماكن المحدده في الوقت المناسب طيب
زيدان ماذا بالنسبه للبناء التحتيه الطبيه
هل تستطيع التعامل مع هذا الكم الهائل من
الجرحى هناك حديث عن 16 الف جريح حتى هذه
اللحظه كيف تتعامل المستشفيات والاطقم
الطبيه التركيه مع هذا الكم الهائل من
الجرحى
حتى
التوازن الطبيه في جنوب تركيا في عصر
الولايات او حتى في او حتى المشافي هناك
التقارير الوارده من هناك حتى الان لا
توجد مشكله في استيعاب هذا العدد من
المرضى لكن هناك مشكله ربما ستظهر في
المستقبل في حال ازداد العدد بشكل كبير
هذه نقطه نقطه اخرى
وجود عدد كبير من السكان في اجواء بارزه
في الشوارع هذا
ايضا هؤلاء بحاجه الى توفير الدعم اللازم
لذلك
حتى لا يكون هناك ضغط على المشافي
الحكوميه او حتى الخاصه التي تستقبل
الجرحى الجرحى نتيجه الزلزال سيكون هناك
مشاكل ميدانيه
تهتم بموضوع السكان الذين ما زالوا يبيتون
في العراق وبحاجه الى دعم طبي او نوعا ما
رعايه طبيه ايضا اضافه الى هذا ايضا تهتم
بجرحى او مصابين حتى الان لا توجد مشكله
باستيعاب عدد كبير في استيعاب العدد
الحالي لكن الخشيه هي من زياده عدد
المصابين بشكل اكبر وايضا
وجود حالات مرضيه بين
الاشخاص الذين يبيتون في الاراء او حتى في
اماكن اللواء بما ان درجات الحراره متدنيه
وهذا يؤدي ربما الى انتشار الامراض وايضا
الانفلونزا بين السكان خصوصا بين الاطفال
طب زيدان كثير من الدول بالامس يعني بعد
حصول هذه الكارثه اعلنت بانها سترسل اطقم
اغا مساعدات ايضا من
كافه الانواع لتركيا هل بدات تصل هذه
القوافل
تحدثنا قبل قليل
القوافل بدات تصل الى القوافل كانت وصلت
370 شخص
وانقر يعني اخر تصريح في هذا النصوص من
قبل السلطات تركيا عنا القوافل تتجه الى
تركيا هذا الحديث كان يوم امس هناك
حوالي اكثر من اربعين دوله ابدت استعدادها
لارسال المساعدات ثلاثه عشر دوله اوروبيه
والبقيه هنا الدول العربيه وايضا الولايات
المتحده وايضا هناك
مجموعه من الدول ترسل مساعدات لنتحدث يعني
الاسماء التي تخطر لي حاليا مثلا روسيا
الولايات المتحده بريطانيا اسبانيا فرنسا
رومانيا بلغاريا
اسرائيل ايضا الصين وهناك من الدول
العربيه
مصر تونس الكويت قطري هذه الاسماء التي
تتذكرها على عجاله كل هؤلاء يرسلون او
بداوا فعلا بارسال مساعدات الى تركيا او
اطقم طبيه وايضا اتقن انقاذ متخصصه
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول كان معنا مراسله
العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا تقع تركيا على عده خطوط صدى
رئيسيه ما يجعلها منطقه
ناشطه للزلازل الارضيه
الهزات الارضيه ظواهر متكرره الحدوث في
تركيا تعود الى وقوع معظم اجزاء تركيا على
الصفيحه الاناضليه التي تتموضع بين
الصفيحه الاوراسيه التي تمثل نسبيا قشره
غير قابله للحركه والصفيحه العربيه التي
تتجه شمالا بمعدل بوصه واحده تقريبا سنويا
يؤدي هذا الى ضغط تركيا التي تقف على عده
خطوط السطع اكثر خطوط الصدع تدميرا في
تركيا هو خط الصدع شمال الاناضول حيث
تلتقي صفي الاناضول والاوراسيا هذا ويمتد
خط الصدع شمال الاناضول من جنوب اسطنبول
مباشره على طول الطريق الى شمال شرق تركيا
كذلك يمتد خط صدع شرق الاناضول حوالي 650
كيلو مترا من مرتفعات شرق تركيا الى البحر
المتوسط حيث يتجه جنوبا ويلتقي في النهايه
مع الصدع الكبير الذي يفصل بين الصفائح
الافريقيه
العربيه ملوك الشيخ العربيه
هذا وتتعرض تركيا باستمرار لزلازل وهزات
ارضيه حصدت ارواح الاف الضحايا ودمرت
المباني والبنى التحتيه
منذ عام 1500 شهيد التركي نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاتيك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 20300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمصر ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
زلزال غول تشيك بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله
اثنين تسبب بمسرع
894 شخصا
زلزالو فان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
ابرز الزلازل المميته حول العالم في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس عام 2021
درجه ومقتل ما يزيد عن 2200 شخص
في السادس عشر من ابريل عام 2016
الاكوادور زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ومقتل 650
شخصا
في الخامس والعشرين من ابريل عام 2015
نيبال زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه وتسبب بمقتل
تسعه الاف شخص
الحادي عشر من مارس عام 2011 اليابان
زلزال مدمر بقوه تسع درجات خلف عشرين الفا
بين قتيل ومفقود السادس والعشرون من
ديسمبر عام 2003 ايران زلزال بقوه 6.6
درجه اسفر عن مقتل 31 الف شخص
ننتقل الى سوريا حيث اظهرت لقطات محاوله
فرق الانقاذ مساعده العالقين تحت الانقاض
وتقديم المساعدات اللازمه في بلده الاتارب
بيري في حلب الغربي بعد زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
كما ظهر مقطع فيديو بلده عزمارين في ريفي
حلب بسوريا حيث تبدو المنازل سويت بالارض
بفعل الزلزال القوي
معنى لا مشاهدينا من عمان الصحفيه السوريه
زياد الريس اهلا او الريس اهلا بك استاذ
زياد معنا استاذ زياد كيف تبدو الاوضاع
الان في المناطق المنكوبه من سوريا في حلب
وريفها هل ما زالت اعمال الانقاذ مستمره
ويعني عدد الضحايا حتى هذه اللحظه
نعم صباح الخير لكم وصباح الخير استاذ
المشاهدين طبعا الاوضاع ماساويه جدا حقيقه
العمليات الانقاذ يعني عائل المنقذين
عاجزون طبعا بكل تاكيد ان هناك ليس هناك
خبراء في هذه العمليه ولا يوجد معدات
واليات للانقاذ يعني هناك حاله فقر لهذه
الاليات لا يوجد تعاون ايضا من من الحكومه
في دمشق ان ترسل المعدات سواء كان الى حلب
او حتى الى حماه ايضا يعني الوضع في
اللاذقيه في عمليات الانقاذ هو افضل حال
ليس لان هناك اهتمام من السلطه لان
المنطقه تمتلك معدات واليات في مدينه حلب
وحقيقه الان يعني هناك رسائل تقول انه
منزل 26 ساعه هناك الاهداف من الاشخاص في
الشوارع لم يتناولوا حتى الطعام ولم
ياتيهم اي مساعدات غذائيه بل على عكس ذلك
هناك اشاعات في كل ساعه هناك اشاعات تقول
ان هناك زلزال جديد يؤدي هذا الامر الى
هروب المدنيين والسكان الشوارع ثم يكتشف
ان هناك عمليات سرقه منظمه تحصل بهذه
البيوت وسط غياب كامل لاي رقابه امنيه واي
سلطه امنيه هناك لغايه الان المئات تحت
الانقاضاف تحت الانقاذ خاصه نتحدث عن حي
سليمان الحلبي نتحدث دوله في حالات حي
الفردوس يعني هناك ابنيه باكملها منها
هناك ابنيه ايضا لا زالت تنهار نتيجه
الهزات الارتداديه يعني قبل ساعات تقريبا
قبل ساعات الفجر بقليل ايضا نهار احد
المباني يقارن في اكثر من سته او شبه
اطفال مع سيدات ورجل ويحاولون الان الوصول
اليهم لا يوجد معدات تقوم بفتح الطرقات
كثيره
تكدس الاتربه والردم في هذه
الاحياء هناك مساعدات نسمع مساعدات لكن
لغايه الان لم تصل لشاحنات مساعدات حقيقيه
الى المناطق تقول استاذ زياد بانه ما زالت
هناك بعض الابنيه الان يعني في ساعات
الفجر الاولى ما زالت نهار نتيجه لهزات
ارتداديه وتحديدا في حلب هذا الكلام يحصل
نعم تماما هذا ما حصل هذا قبل ساعات
المؤلف من ثلاث طواب يعني يقارن فيه اطفال
بعدد يعني مدينه سته سبعه او ثمانيه اطفال
والسيدات هذا ما يحصل فعلا وهناك الكثير
من الادنى المتضرره عاد السكان لها في
مجازفه واضحه وسط غياب كامل حتى للاعلام
الرسمي للتوعيه يعني الناس تعبت جدا لا
يوجد من قائمه بنصف خيام مثلا على الاقل
تقدير في الحدائق لكي يتم الاطفال والنساء
البعض جالسا في حياتي وعادوا الى منازلهم
رغم ان هناك صور تظهر الخطر هناك خطيره
يعني بعض العائلات التقط صور لمنازلها
هناك تصدعات وشقوق بشكل عرضي وهذا يؤدي
الى ان يرى المبنى سواء بهزار ارتداء او
حتى بدون هزه يمكن ان ينار المصدر لكن لا
نستطيع ان نفعل شيء يعني بالنهايه لا يوجد
سلطه على الارض يمكن ان تقنع الاشخاص انه
سيتم مساعدتكم عليك عليكم الالتزام
بالبقاء خارج المنزل لم يتم تامين ايواء
حقيقي فعلا لم يعلن عن فتح المدارس لم
يعلن عن فتح المساجد يعني هناك حقيقه هناك
اهمال كبير متعمد على ما يبدو في مدينه
حلب من قبل الحكومه السوريه يعني التي لا
ترسل اي مساعدات الى تلك المنطقه طيب
استاذ زياد كان هناك ايضا حديث بالامس
واعلان من كثير من الدول ومنها الولايات
المتحده بانها مستعده لارسال مساعدات فرق
انقاذ
اطقم طبيه الى سوريا اذا طلبت ذلك ولكن
يعني مع الوضع الذي تصفه بانه حتى الحكومه
السوريه لا تهتم بهذه المناطق المنكوبه
معنى ذلك بانه من غير المرجح ان يصل هذه
المناطق اي مساعدات حتى من الخارج
تماما يعني لم يطلب النظام او لم يصرح
النظام انه حتى بحاجه الى اي اغاثه او انه
بحاجه الى اي مساعده والنظام عليه ان يبدي
استعداده لاستقبال المساعدات وحمايه فرق
الاغاثه في حاله قررت احدى الدول ارسال
فرق وقررت المنظمات لكن هو الذي لم يفعل
ذلك حتى ان النظام يقوم باستقبال
المساعدات في مطار دمشق الدولي علما ان
المنطقه المنكوبه الاكثر في سوريا هي حلب
التي تبعد 400 كيلو متر والنظام يدعي ان
لديه عجز في قطاع النفط وقطاع الطاقه
وبالتالي نقل
المواد الغذائيه الى حالات سيكون مربط
بالنسبه للنظام خاصه الاجواء الان لماذا
لا يتم ارسال هذه المساعدات الى مطار حلب
لا يريد النظام ذلك طبعا مطار حلب موجود
في النظام وروسيا وايران هناك يستطيع
النظام على اقل تقدير ان يقول ان مطار حلب
الان هو استثنائيا يستقبل كل شحنات وكل
شرح تعليقاتها اذا كان فعلا صادق تريد
ارسال ذلك ونعم طائرات فعلا هبطت في مطار
دمشق الدولي وافرغت شحنات من الاغذيه
والادويه خاصه وصلت قبل قليل وصلنا ان
هناك طائرات رقم ساده تقريبا ثالث طائره
تصل من العراق وصلت من ايران معنا الدول
العربيه قدمت لكن لغايه لكم احياء حلب
ومدينه حلب لم تعرض شيء يسمى اغاثه حتى
المبادرات الفرديه لا يوجد من يتعاون معهم
هناك احد الاشخاص قال انه لديه سيارات
الاسعاف فقط هو يحتاج وقود ولا يريد هذا
الوقود مجانا نريده بشمل فقط على الحكومه
او على احد المتنفذين ان يوفر شكرا جزيلا
لك استاذ زياد الريس كان معنا من عمان
ومشاهدينا اشكر لكم حسن المتابعه واعود
القاكم بعد لحظات في نشره اخرى الى اللقاء